that we don't get into another time lik
with somebody somebody because he's
talking spelling Twitter we continue to
be an economic and political and social
powerhouse we should start limiting the
people who do come into America because
even though not everyone be a terrorist
or is you know a danger to our nation we
need to be careful moving and really
protected people who are here I think
America needs to be America I don't
think we need to answer to anyone I
think that were the greatest country in
the world because we can do what we want
in a respectful manner the rest of the
world through various organizations I
may be able to influence from just a
little bit and raina men you want to end
the conflict with Palestine and Israel
we want to help Syrian refugees and we
make friends with most of our current
enemies such as like Russia hopefully
there's a little bit of fear with the
unknown just as we have here in this
country we have no idea what he's going
to do next the best-case scenario for
America's role in the world they could
be a leader without being a bully he
loses his fascination with Putin and
decides to follow international norms
and behaviors that were there with Obama
and before Obama that once again will be
defined as the best worst case scenario
is that he says something on Twitter
that pisses somebody off and starts the
world war three we will keep pushing our
ideals on other countries and cultures
and causing Wars and famine and other
problems in the rest of the world will
be the laughingstock no one would take
America seriously if we continue to
intervene with nations in the Middle
East we're going to have significant
amount of wars occurrence no longer you
spend tweeting about that you know
Sweeting about actresses and their
golden globe speeches so less and less
that people are going to see him as the
legitimate leader north case scenario is
that thing to stay the same
you can't get anywhere
[Music]